vancsik un valle en el interior de
afganistán con una única carretera de
115 km este fue el último bastión de
resistencia contra el régimen talibán en
septiembre pasado los fundamentalistas
finalmente conquistaron a la tierra del
comandante ahmad zia masud cuyos
retratos han sido destruidos hoy
controlan el valle con puño de hierro
han establecido puestos de control a lo
largo de la vía principal cruzamos cinco
controles antes de llegar a pasar a la
capital de la provincia pongan un puesto
de control aquí
revisen todos los vehículos que pasen
que hay en esa bolsa granos
tarapoto
vosotras de mendoza
por lo general nos concentramos en
encontrar drogas que se vayan a traficar
sobre todo hachís y cocaína
también atrapamos personas que llevan
armas sin autorización
hacemos los controles para prevenir
todos esos actos
gracias adiós fans ir es la provincia
más segura de afganistán
el talibán afirma que el valle ha sido
pacificada y que el movimiento de
resistencia nacional liderado por el
hijo de ahmad zia masud fue neutralizado
pero según los líderes del movimiento
que se han refugiado en el extranjero el
frente sigue activo en el terreno no se
han reportado más enfrentamientos
hemos oído que aquí hay algunas personas
resistiendo pero en el terreno no hemos
visto nada concreto y tampoco no nos
hemos encontrado no creo que esas
personas ni su resistencia realmente
existan
en la cima de la colina de esa dicha un
grupo de combatientes talibanes custodia
la tumba de ahmad zia masud algunos son
nativos del valle de panchir
toda la seguridad de la tumba de mazón
está bajo jurisdicción
yo controlo este lugar todos los
hermanos hermanas y ciudadanos tienen
permitido venir y visitar la tumba de
matutes pueden tomar fotos caminar y ver
que la tumba sigue en buen estado
hasta mediados de septiembre los
combates causaban estragos en el valle
de bungee obligaron a 28.000 locales a
abandonar sus hogares según las naciones
unidas diez mil habitantes de panshir
aún no han regresado mahmud viví hace
parte de las pocas personas que se
quedaron aquí murieron nueve personas
para seis de ellos di palas y sábanas
para que los enterrarán en este lugar no
eran combatientes sino civiles estaban
tratando de huir al pueblo para ande al
otro lado de la colina pero les
dispararon desde abajo no salí durante
el combate era demasiado violento
esta mujer viuda vive en un pueblo
abandonado junto con su hijo
discapacitado
su nuera que era profesora y que perdió
su trabajo a causa de la llegada del
régimen talibán y sus hijos
después de la caída del gobierno
anterior el talibán tomó el control y
empezaron los problemas para nosotras
porque dejamos de recibir nuestros
salarios
este es todo el arroz que tenemos
el poco de madera y carbón que nos
quedan
acosta algunos dicen que vendrá la ayuda
humanitaria pero por ahora seguimos
esperando y confiando en ala
por primera vez desde la llegada del
régimen talibán se volvió a reanudar la
ayuda humanitaria en tánger el alto
comisionado de naciones unidas para los
refugiados distribuye entre 260 y 400
dólares por familia
utilizar el dinero para comprar cosas
para el invierno como madera carbón y
gas los precios de los productos básicos
han subido mucho alrededor de 600
hogares recibirán esa ayuda
ponga su huella aquí y después aquí
también en el cupón
su número de registro es el 185
lo que es necesario entender es que la
situación económica es extremadamente
mala y que los últimos eventos la han
empeorado todavía más la guerra en
panshir ha destruido muchas casas y las
personas han perdido su ganado la
capital de la provincia es ahora un
pueblo fantasma sus calles antes llenas
de vida ahora están vacías los mercados
permanecen bajo la constante vigilancia
de los talibanes que se han vuelto los
nuevos clientes en esta tienda un hombre
se atreve a hablar con nosotros por su
seguridad no revelaremos su rostro en mi
familia esposaron a dos de mis primos y
le dispararon eran inocentes los mataron
sin razón sin que hubiesen cometido
ningún crimen y eso ocurrió cuando la
guerra había terminado en una situación
como ésta ya no nos sentimos seguros
llegar hasta ahí si das panshir es el
mismo panshir de antes panshir no
cambiará nunca para mí el único cambio
verdadero es que antes se nos gobernaban
la policía y el ejército y ahora el
talibán
antes una zona rebelde ahora el valle
parece un territorio ocupado algo nunca
antes visto en la historia de países